I like to put it like this when the
limestone of imperative programming has
worn away the Granite's a functional
programming will be revealed underneath
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using when we
look at a skyscraper or a suspension
bridge a simple search engine box on a
screen looks tiny by comparison but dr.
Simon Paton Jones would like to remind
us that computer programs with hundreds
of millions of lines of code are
actually among the largest structures
human beings have ever built a principal
researcher at the Microsoft research lab
in Cambridge England co-developer of the
programming language Haskell and a
fellow of Britain's Royal Society
Simon Paton Jones has dedicated his life
to this very particular kind of
construction work today dr. Peyton Jones
shares his passion for functional
programming research reveals how a
desire to help other researchers write
and present better turned him into an
unlikely YouTube star and explains why
at least in the world of programming
languages purity is embarrassing
laziness is cool and success should be
avoided at all costs that and much more
on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
Simon welcome you're in the programming
principles and tools group at Microsoft
Research in Cambridge what do you spend
most of your time doing there
well programming language is the
fundamental material out of which we
build programs when a builder built a
building they can build out a brick so
out of straw out of bananas or out of
steel girders and it makes a difference
what you build out of how ambitious your
building can be and how likely it is to
fall down so when developers write
programs the material that they use the
fabric of their programs that is the
programming language is super important
to the robustness and longevity and
reliability of their programs so
programming language researchers study
programming languages with the aim of
building more robust building materials
for developers to use what role does
research play in making good programming
languages well at first you might think
that a programming language was well he
just kind of threw it together but
actually when you build a program in our
which you want to be sure that you know
what it means that is to say if you
write a program you'd like it to be
clear what the program means what should
happen when you execute it that's called
its semantics so having a good way to
specify in a rigorous way what that
program means what it does is really
important so we need to find formalisms
that we can write down rigorously what a
program means and then we need to
implement it so if we're going to build
a compiler that say translates a high
level language program it's a low level
machine code is going to run on your
machine you'd like to be confident that
the compiler itself was correct right
that is that it didn't change the
meaning of the program along the way and
it would do so consistently and reliably
day after day on program after program
after program so programming language
research is about methods and tools and
techniques and ideas and theories that
will enable people to build programming
language designs and implementations
that will be robust I wouldn't say that
programming languages tend to arise
specifically from academics having
clever ideas about what a language
design might look like they're very
often born in a much more random way in
the white heat of I just need to get
something done and then retrospectively
programming language designers and
researchers start to look closely at the
design and try to improve it so there's
been dozens and dozens of papers about
JavaScript for example but JavaScript
was not designed initially done academic
I've seen your talks and you use some
slides that show sort of the trajectory
of a lot of different languages you've
suggested that there's hundreds of
languages most of them share the fate of
an early death with only one or two at
the memorial service and then there's
some that just resonate and take off
what does it take to make it big and is
that something you should aim for so I
think every computer scientist wants
their language to be used that's one of
the exciting things are working
Microsoft research is that there's a
real chance your stuff might get used
and have impact so we all want to make
the world a better place in programming
language research I would say that while
everybody would aspire to have languages
that have impact in a successful it's
putting random which ones are the ones
that are wildly successful and not
necessarily the ones that are
technically beautiful or well designed
they just hit some sweet spot at some
particular moment that's a bit
frustrating in a way I think the you
know Haskell the language that I've been
involved in has been quite successful
but it could easily not have been
there's a lot of randomness in the
process you mentioned two giants in
computer science Alan Turing and Alonzo
Church who came up with ideas at about
the same time that have had a big impact
on programming languages in two
different streams I think he talked
about declarative and imperative
languages talk about that for a minute
so my entire research life ever since I
first got excited about functional
programming at when I was studying at
Cambridge in 1979 of there abouts my
entire research life has been following
through the idea what might be
functional programming mean and if you
look back a long way as you say it does
all date back to and Alonzo Church and
Alan Turing to pick just two giants from
the literature so chewing said what is
computation what does it mean to compute
something and he designed this thing we
now called the Turing machine that was a
very much step at a time do this do this
reader thing from the tape write that
onto the tape it was a very imperative
machine meanwhile at the very same time
actually in the same place it was in
Princeton
Alonzo Church was designing the lambda
calculus which is a Alma kind of seems
much more abstract algebraic thing it's
like rewriting expressions and he
discovered this tiny language in which
expression rewrites could also
apparently model computation so then it
seemed obvious to ask is there anything
you could compute with the Turing
machine that you couldn't compute with
lambda calculus or vice versa and in the
end it turned out very surprisingly that
these two notions of computation were
the same that is anything you could do
could the Turing machine you could do
with lambda calculus and vice versa but
although they were equally powerful in
the sense of what can you in principle
do they gave rise to very different
language streams so two machines
ultimately you could see this is a bit
of a retrospective justification but you
could see that CTO machines as the basis
for all imperative languages right do
this and then do that step at a time
computation in which the program is a
sequence of steps that you do in
sequence lambda calculus is then the
grandmother of functional programming in
which you program executes by evaluation
you evaluate an expression and it it
seems like completely different ways
about thinking about your program you
have to think about programming in a
completely different way but
nevertheless they're equally expressive
so the interest for me has been what
would it mean to take this much less
popular but nevertheless universal
programming power down of functional
programming and really push it through
to see what could that mean in a
practical way for writing practical
programs so talk about the difference
between functional programming languages
and other programming languages the
imperative approach step at a time
programming is what everybody's used to
it's what C is like Java is like C++ is
like Python is like Perl is like Ruby is
like you know you name it they're mostly
imperative programming languages
functional programming is very different
it's more like everybody's used a
spreadsheet and in a spreadsheet cell
you say here is a formula that gives the
value of a cell and you compute the
value of a whole spreadsheet full of
cells by computing each cell perhaps one
at a time perhaps in parallel but in
data dependency order
if cell a1 depends on cell b3 you must
compute cell b3 first and then a1 but
there's no notion of open a valve or
launch the missiles or print something
you can't do that in the middle of a
formula it wouldn't make sense so that's
functional programming right all of the
excels built-in functions are functions
that is to say they take some inputs and
they produce some outputs they have no
side effects and so the surprising thing
really is that this purely functional
approach to programming is in fact
universal if you think about it in a
spreadsheet way think well that's good
enough for writing business plans maybe
or computing my bank balance but it
couldn't do anything useful could you
write a word processor in a spreadsheet
well probably not right but the insight
of functional programming which stems
right back to church is that this
programming paradigm is universal you
can do anything and so the you know
functional programming man which
researchers have said supposingly took
that execution by evaluation idea and
scaled it up what would that mean and
that's what my whole research life has
been about really why did you get
interested in that I mean at the very
beginning because it's like a a radical
and elegant attack on the entire
enterprise of programming well then just
think well let's just try doing this a
slightly different way it's like saying
let's just attack programming from a
completely different direction moreover
it's very close to mathematics the whole
idea of lambda calculus would really go
out of logic and there's very beautiful
dualities between programming on the one
hand and logic on the other it's called
the curry Howard isomorphism in which
you can view a let's say I have a
function whose type is it takes some two
integers and it produces an integer well
that type tells you something about the
program so in a sense it's a weak
theorem about the program it tells you
something about the program but not
everything and indeed you could regard
the program as a proof of that theorem
so the idea of types as theorems and
programs as proofs is a very deep
connection between logic on the one hand
and programming on the other and this
duality is very immediate in functional
programming but it's rather distant and
imperative programming
so I tried to give you a sense for what
got me excited about it I just got
excited about it because thought it's
such a beautiful simple elegant way of
thinking about the enterprise of
programming let's see if we can make it
practical I love that now how many
people are in your is camp the right
word because you have people writing
imperative languages all over the place
is this something that needs to be
evangelized functional languages sure
yes
so no I like to put it like this when
the limestone of imperative programming
has worn away the granite a functional
programming will be revealed underneath
so imperative programming is very
appealing don't get me wrong right it's
sort of what real machines do if you
look at what a microprocessor does it
does loads and stores and ads and it
sets things in registers that make
valves go open or launches the missiles
or prints something like functional
programming is a bit more abstract so
that's why it's been a sort of minority
pursuit for a long time and over I guess
the 40-year period of my adventure with
functional programming it's gradually
infected the mainstream more and more
but not too fast that's quite important
right avoid success at all costs is one
of my little mottos right because we do
successful too quickly you get sort of
stuck and you can't change anything
anymore but functional programming has
become more and more influential we can
talk about ways in which that has
happened well I do want to talk about
Haskell and what you've just said about
the slow burn the slow rise and the
benefits of not getting too successful
too quickly or dying in early death but
having the tenacity to stay there for
long enough to start to grow and get
more useful yes so for me one of the
glories and privileges of being a
research computer scientist is that
you're not just allowed but actually
paid to work on a simple and elegant
idea and to do so for no 35 or 40 years
that's amazing that society allows us to
do that so as far as Haskell goes I mean
you don't just want to work on abstract
ideas you want to work on things that
have impact
so Haskell was developed by a group of
research colleagues around the world
including myself and oh I D was just to
embody the current consensus among
ourselves about what purely functional
programming actually was let pure lazy
functional programming might look like
and at that time it was very much a
university enterprise but by having an
actual language and then turning it into
an actual compiler that people could
actually use to get their job done and
then extending the compiler so we could
deal with input/output and we could do
with foreign function interface and talk
to see and so forth and we could develop
the time sistah to actually be useful
over time we've turned Haskell into
something that is useful for practical
applications and now in fact it's really
quite widely used by developers in
mostly small companies so let's talk
about laziness for a little bit when I
was growing up that wasn't a virtuous
quality in our household but some how
lazy functional computing is a good
thing why is that oh yes yes so at first
it was just an amazingly clever and
elegant thing so laziness is the idea
that if you call a function in a normal
imperative language or call-by-value
language then before calling the
function you're going to evaluate the
arguments to the values of those
arguments and then you pass them to the
function in a lazy functional language
you don't evaluate the arguments before
passing them to the function you create
recipes or suspensions or thunks which
you pass to the function and if it needs
that argument then it will evaluate it
so you can write a function that might
evaluate one or other but not both of
its arguments and that can be super
important just think of a function like
if a conditional where you don't want to
evaluate both the then branch and the
else bunch so why did that happen well
firstly it was because we could because
the lambda calculus a program in the
lambda calculus is an expression that
you evaluate and when you evaluate an
expression like if I evaluate the
arithmetic expression three plus four
times seven plus eight then I could
evaluate the three plus four first or
the seven plus eight first there isn't
an inherent order in expression
evaluation except that I must evaluate
the three plus four and the seven plus
eight before I multiply them
right so there's some data dependencies
but there's a lot of fluidity about
evaluation order and it's the same with
the lambda calculus and it turns out
there's a lot of study in the
theoretical literature about evaluation
order and some of these evaluation
orders called normal order naturally led
to lazy evaluation we thought oh that's
interesting
oh it's just sort of naturally arises
what would that be good for the first we
just thought it was cool and then John
Hughes wrote this very interesting paper
called why functional programming
matters in which she said laziness is
not just cool it's useful and he did
that by describing how laziness gives
you a new form of modularity and his
classic example was this supposing I'm
writing a program to play chess well one
thing I might do is explore the tree of
possible moves he can move this way then
I could move that way then you could
move that way there's a big tree suppose
I first generated a tree and then pruned
it to figure out the best move well
actually would be too big so usually we
would have to generate and prune at the
same time and John said well no with
lazy evaluation you can generate in one
piece of program and tune in another and
that gives you new form of modularity so
that was really an interesting idea this
worked out exactly that way I love it
and I'll probably use it that laziness
is not just cool but useful it is not
just cool but useful yes how did
laziness and purity come together so
Haskell's initial defining
characteristic was that it was a lazy
language that's what brought that
particular group of people together what
we thought was exciting and cool but in
retrospect I now think what was much
more important was that laziness forced
Haskell to be a pure language by which I
mean in a call-by-value functional
language like ml or Lisp if you wanted
to print something it was too tempting
to have a function in quotes which when
you call it would print something as a
side effect that is it wouldn't just
return well what would print return unit
or three or something but it would print
something on the side so we couldn't do
that in a lazy language because we
couldn't predict the evaluation order
one enough so laziness kept us pure and
purity was embarrassing for a long time
because you couldn't really do much by
way of input/output you couldn't print
things or open files or launch missiles
or or sale about
so that forced us to invent what came to
be called monadic input-output and there
was another classic example in which
Phil Wadler my colleague at Glasgow took
ideas from the logic world the theory of
monads developed by various people but
he was particularly drawing on the work
of a Eugenia Maji who is very much a
theorist Phil whatever this wonderful
paper comprehending monads in which he
described known as I say programming
idiom and then he and I subsequently
wrote a paper called imperative
functional programming which showed how
you could apply monadic programming to
do input/output to affect the world and
that idea has been wildly infectious
that spread to all sorts of places so
people now use the monadic thought
patent as a design idea for designing
their programming languages a waste to
you could see it all over the place now
but the own only happened because we
were stuck with purity because we had
laziness it was another place with a
sort of theory both help to the practice
and also almost forced the practice but
we would have had to break with our
principles too much to just have
side-effects so we were stuck with no
side effects and were forced to invent
this alternative we're going bad things
[Music]
aside from your pioneering work in
functional programming language is a
good part of what you do involves
inspiring the next generation to take up
the computer science baton and run with
it how have you gone about doing that
what have you done in the inspiration
business for computer science I started
with this about ten years ago when my
children were at school and now we would
sit on the dim table they would tell me
what they thought they did at school and
they had complete contempt for their
lessons in ICT information and
communication technology and so in
talking to them I was unable to make any
connection between the subject that I
thought was so interesting that I
devoted my professional life to it and
the subject that they were learning in
school and that was different to say
biology in which I think of biologists
sitting around the dinner table with
their children would be able to make a
connection between the subject
discipline that their children even at
Primary School were learning at school
and the subject discipline that they
thought was so interesting they devoted
their professional life to it
so that seemed like a very big
disconnect the more people I talk to the
more people said well yeah it doesn't
make sense but that's the way it is so I
helped start an outfit called computing
at school which is based in the UK but
open to anybody anywhere in the world
whose sole mission was to try to say
what might it mean to teach computer
science as a subject discipline to
school children and to teach it at the
same levels and for the same reasons
that we teach natural science or
mathematics that is not because they
were going to become physicists or
mathematicians necessarily a few will
but most will not but because knowing
some elementary principles about the
physical or chemical biological or
digital world that surrounds them will
make them more empowered better informed
citizens and that applies from primary
school onwards so that was the mission
of computing at school it's now part of
the core curriculum in the UK that's
right so we were unexpectedly successful
and we started in 2007 8 it was like we
felt as if we were at the bottom of the
deep well no shouting up towards the
daylight no computer science is
important you know we got lucky we wrote
a curriculum there was a review of the
entire National Curriculum
serendipitously
started by the then conservative
government so we were ready to make
inputs of that curriculum debate and in
the end we achieved almost all our
policy goals the new National Curriculum
for computing in England pretty much
says in black and white all children
should learn the fundamental principles
that could be discerned switch to do so
from primary school onwards so that's
amazing that came into force in 2014 but
there's a big challenge after that it's
like when you scale one apparently
unsurmountable mountain what do you find
behind it another bigger mountain in
this case it's how do we turn that
aspirational idea into a tangible and
living reality in every classroom in the
land and that is a big challenge because
while teachers are willing and committed
and hardworking and able they're by and
large not qualified in computer science
so there's a lot to do there's a lot to
do the state in this country is pockets
of excellence but it overall it's quite
fragile I think that in various stages
most countries in the world are facing
the same issues within policy goals and
implementation and then how do you
prepare teachers we're watching the UK I
think yeah I think every you know pretty
much every nation in the world is
thinking hard about what they teach
their children about computing and how
they go about teaching it and I don't
think anybody has a monopoly on truth
here we're all trying to figure it out
as we go along do you think there's any
room in the research community for this
kind of line of inquiry Oh
tremendous yes sir both among computer
scientists who I think individually and
collectively computer scientists should
be active in talking to their local
school teachers in being on school
boards of Governors because there's a
seismic change taking place it's like
establishing an entirely new subject at
school level and what is that entirely
new subjects well it's called computer
science and who would know about that
well computer scientists particularly
research computer scientists so we may
not know how to teach we may not know
much about children but we know the
subject discipline so we should get
involved but the other thing that the
research and we need is research in
education right because computer
scientists know nothing about education
what is good pedagogy for
or computer science concept how might
you teach computational thinking what
role does formative assessment play how
could you use you know hinge-point
questions to teach computing more
effectively when we teach programming
does it make sense to start from a blank
sheet of paper and say write a program
to do X or should we instead spend a lot
of time showing programs and saying
please explain to your neighbor how this
works or here's a program with a bug in
it please find the bug and explain
what's wrong and fix it do you a lot of
different approaches to how you go about
teaching and we need educational
research in the end backed by research
evidence to say which of these
approaches works better I think you've
just given any number of listeners to
this podcast some ideas about where they
might want to go with research in the
future if they have a passion for
education and for computer science yeah
this is it the intersection of Education
and computer science is a very rich area
at the moment and everybody wants to
make a difference to the education that
we give our children because many of us
have children and what a them see them
succeed listen let's talk about another
intersection that you're really
interested in theory and practice
computer science is unusual like if
you're in biology then just finding out
something that is true is progress and
novelty has value in its own right
that's true of any Natural Science in
computer science novelty has no value in
and of itself it's too easy to make up
new stuff it's a kind of like a fractal
discipline everywhere you dig you can
make new details were creating ideas out
of nothing how to pure thought stuff
Fred Brooks had this wonderful newell
award lecturers called the computer
scientists this tool smith and he says
computer science and it's theories only
have value insofar as they demonstrate
utility so it's a question asked about
every paper every research proposal I
see it's not just ideas but utility so
to return to your question then about
theory and practice
nevertheless it's much more fun if
theory and practice live quite close
together if you can use a piece of
theory to give practical results you
know and make that crossover without you
know bending the theory too much out of
shape and in functional programming
that's particularly true so for example
in that compiler that we built the
Haskell
it's called GHC we were struggling in
the very
early 90s to think what should its
intermediate language be like Haskell's
vote large sauce language we compile it
into a small intermediate language that
we will then transform optimize
transform and optimize and then finally
spit out machine code watch that
intermediate language be we want it to
be strongly typed itself and I was
worrying about oh where could we put the
types and how would they live and how
would they survive transformation and
fill Wadler said to me you know what
Simon we should use system F I sort of
walked back in my chair and thought
system F I learned about that in an
extremely theoretical seminar that I
went to run by Samson Adamski I thought
that was a purely theoretical interest
but it turned out we ended up directly
implementing system F in GHC and it's
still there to this day it's a very pure
embodiment of an idea that was developed
solely in the theory context but turned
out to have immediate practical utility
and that happens again and again in
functional programming I love that
[Music]
I want to ask you about a couple of
videos here in that have tens of
thousands of downloads on YouTube about
how to write a research paper and how to
give a research talk could you talk
about that a little bit and why that was
important to you and how that came about
that you became a video star on YouTube
well a lot of search is about
communicating as I say in these talks no
matter how brilliant you are if you sit
in a sealed room and have fantastic
ideas but don't tell anybody then all
you've done is heat up the universe
really made it a better place so
communication is key I think I'm at the
first of these that was about how to
give a talk with John Hughes and John
Lurie after we were colleagues in the
same department we been through a lot of
research talks we started talking to
each other about couldn't a lot of these
talk to be a lot better with some quite
simple suggestions so then we wrote them
down in a simple and notices paper and I
gave a talk about it and then
subsequently I developed a talk about
how to write a research paper which has
been extremely popular and it was and it
arose in the same way I just thought I'm
reading a lot of papers I'm reviewing a
lot of papers and some quite simple
ideas that field could make them a lot
better and so I thought that it was
worth putting a bit of effort into
trying to articulate or distill the
techniques or ideas that I used in the
hope they'd be useful to others and to
my astonishment they seemed to have been
quite widely looked at including by
people in completely different
disciplines but absolutely in history
it's really strange I get email from the
most remarkable places yeah I think if
in terms of citations or views or
webpage hits all the rest of this
functional programming stuff is you know
[Laughter]
one of the most interesting things I
heard you say is that computer programs
are among the largest structures are the
largest things humans have ever built
and when we look at other structures
they seem enormous to our eyes but
people don't usually see the millions of
lines of code behind a very small thing
like a search engine box why do you tell
that story and what's important for us
to understand about that I think that's
by and large ninety-nine point
9% of the population has no visceral
sort of gut feel but just how
complicated remarkable and fragile our
software infrastructure is the search
box looks simple but there's the
millions of lines of code but if you
could see that in the way that you can
see a you know an aircraft carrier or
some complicated machine you can see
inside you'd have a more visceral sense
for how amazing it is that it works at
all still less that it works so well but
you don't get that sense from a computer
program because it's so tiny but all of
my intellectual output from my entire
life including GHC would easily fit on a
USB stick on that little thumbnail size
thing I've just changed someone's two
zeros and some zeros two ones and all
the ones and zeros were there to begin
with all I've done is changed the state
of some of them as my entire
professional output and yet these
artifacts are so complex and so large
they need entirely new techniques for
dealing with them so if you think about
how a large piece of software go we
built it with layer upon layer of
abstraction or we build libraries which
hide their insides but provide an API
that you can call and you build another
library on top of that and another
library on top of that and so we manage
the complexity of these gigantic systems
by building abstractions and learning
how to describe those abstractions I
mean it's another big part of what
programming language people are
interested in right so why is that
important one I would like people who
are not computer scientists to have the
idea that there's something rather
amazing going on and also that it's so
complicated it's not surprising if it
goes wrong occasionally we shouldn't
place too much trust in it right it's
not magic sometimes I think people are
too guilelessly trustworthy of computers
but also for computer scientists or
people thinking about is this a field
I'd like to be interested in the idea of
this whole remarkable Wonderland
of interesting complexity and creativity
why programming is one of the most
creative disciplines in the world you
can create completely new things that
nobody has ever built before that's
something I'd like to get across to
people what's the best thing about being
a researcher to you and why would a
young computer scientist want to follow
in your footsteps in the field of
research
well for me it's been a great privilege
just to be able to take one idea and
follow it through take the idea of
functional programming and run with it
and I being able to do that both at
University for about 15 years 17 years
and then subsequently at Microsoft for
VAR the longer now actually coming up on
20 years at Microsoft and for me it's
been this mixture of elegant theoretical
ideas that have direct practical impact
has always been my powerful motivator so
why might a young person want to be
interested in computing whether in
research or not because you can build
amazing things you know out of this pure
thought stuff why might somebody want to
go and research specifically well
typically if you're working in industry
you're building amazing programs out of
nothing in research you build amazing
ideas out of nothing so as we close what
thoughts would you share about your long
life of research that would give the
next generation say a vision for what
might be next
so I never had a long-term research plan
I never had a oh here are the three big
things I'm going to do with my life and
I'm on this 20-year trajectory to do it
I was always just doing the next thing
so I am not really a very long range
planner but I did have hold of one idea
this functional programming idea I
didn't know how it would turn out but I
just found it fascinating so I would
suggest to younger people just start
with something I remember when I started
as a researcher at University College
London I didn't have a PhD my head of
department gave me some time off to do
research but I had no idea what to do so
I just sat there with a sharp pencil and
a blank sheet of paper hoping for great
ideas to come which of course they
didn't and then my colleague John washe
book he said to me Simon just do
something anything no matter how humble
and simple just start something and so I
did I wrote a little parser generator
for a functional language called SAS
ttle and that eventually turned into a
search paper as it happened so that one
other thing about computer science is
you could start almost anything it'll
turn into something interesting don't
you worried just get started on
something that interests you Simon Paton
Jones thanks for coming all the way over
from England on skype with us today
Oh to learn more about dr. Simon Peyton
Jones and his work in the field of lazy
functional programming languages visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]